[Laughter]
god the moment i saw you last night at
the club
i totally had to ask you out yeah are
you kidding me like the moment oh yeah
that's so
sweet i was actually afraid that you
were going to be like
one of those high maintenance chicks
yeah
what yeah i don't know i don't control
freak or
i don't even know i don't know thank god
that's so funny
isn't it is it is it funny it's fun nah
i'm like i totally just
like to be like easy going yeah yeah i'm
winning
five minutes and we're just now getting
our menus
oh i'm sorry don't be sorry be better
[Music]
right okay i'll be better that's your
job
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill
right yeah yeah you know what i like
about you no what
like you're not afraid to be like brainy
and respectful
right thanks i really like your boobs
i think we really compliment each other
well we just did it right there
and uh i pretty much go with the flow
right right and
is wrong with you excuse me do i look
like mad max to you
i'm sorry do i look like mel gibson with
a mullet
what no not not at all does he look like
a feral child
with a boomerang in his hand no
then why the is water a rare commodity
here it's not
it's not i'm just uh
i'm sorry i'm just really slammed no
you'll know when you're slammed because
your nuts will be on the table and my
fists will be covered in your blood
[Music]
um you were uh
like kind of harsh to that guy
oh him yeah no i was a hostess at a
restaurant
in the industry that's how we talk to
each other i'll show you hey
oh god uh hey
what do you see there that's your water
down down down boy look
then you need okay i have other tables
that i have
ones that look like dm yes there's a
little lipstick on your glasses
but it mean it's yours this is what i
want you to do i want you to take this
glass in the back
i want you to break it take the biggest
shard you can find and bring it to me
and i'm gonna slit your color all right
i'm just i'll get you another one i'm
gonna split your throat
and watch you bleed out and i'm gonna
shower
in your blood all right i'll get another
water well that would be great thank you
but as i was saying like i just feel
like it's like do
unto others
it was your lipstick on the glass
what the hell is that what are you doing
wait wait no no no no
oh my god
i just tell you no one's ever
talked to me like that in my life
have his back who does that it was your
lipstick on the glass
he's just a waiter
you know what take his side i hope you
have a very happy
life together mickey
what's going on right now what do you do
[Music]
seriously me again no no megan
you left the jacket hey you left your
check
hey don't do it
i mean i just heard her feelings and
then she left her jacket at least i
could do something
it backward jack don't do it she's not
needed it's 87 degrees out you know she
doesn't need it in your heart of hearts
you know she doesn't need that jacket
don't do it
i think she's going to need a jacket
she's not you need your jacket though
seem like a nice guy
you